Sal Kahn's response to
the crisis in education
is Kahnacademy.org, a site that lists
a vast and growing collection of his
YouTube video lessons in Math, Physics,
Chemistry, Biology and Economics.
In this conversation with
"Interviews With Innovators"
host, Jon Udell, he discusses his
teaching philosophies and methods and
explains why he abandoned a career in
financial services to become
a new kind of teacher ...
From IT Conversations.
(jazz music)
Phil: Hi, and welcome to IT Conversations.
I'm Phil Windley the Executive Producer.
Today I'm happy to bring
you another program from
Jon Udell's "Interviews With Innovators".
This program is made
possible by Microsoft's
Channel 9 and Channel 10.
Voiceover: Our audio
files are delivered by
Limelight Networks, the
high-performance content delivery
network for digital media.
The Conversations Network
is a 501(c)(3) non-profit
and we need your help.
For a tax-deductible
donation for as little as
$5 per month, you can support this channel
and the rest of the Conversations Network,
so please visit: Conversationsnetwork.org
to become a member and help us continue to
bring our programs to the world for free.
And now, here's John Udell.
Jon: I saw something
online the other evening
that reminded me of what you're doing
in an interesting way, so it might be
a fun place to start.
There's an artist in Los Angeles named
Richard Ankrom and somewhere around
2000 or 2001, he got pissed
off about the fact that
there's this freeway
intersection in Los Angeles
that's very poorly labeled.
In particular, there
was a key missing piece
of information which was a place where
there should have been a
sign that said "North 5".
It just wasn't there.
(laughs) So he went and
made a "North 5" sign
to the Highway Department's
specifications,
then he made himself a uniform,
then he got up on a ladder and
he went out and he installed the thing.
(laughter)
He calls this "Gorilla
Public Service" as in
"Gorilla the Freedom Fighter", not
"Gorilla the Great Ape",
and since then, as far
as I know, it's still up
and probably millions of
people have benefited from that
and it just reminded
me of what you're doing
in a way, in the realm
of education which is
sort of looking at a
situation and thinking,
"You know what? I'm just going to go do
something about that."
Thanks to the technology of the internet,
I can be a super empowered individual,
and there really is essentially no limit
to how far that can scale out and
how many people I can help.
It's really a wonderful thing.
So tell us about the Kahn Academy.
Sal: It's most known for the
roughly 1,200 videos on YouTube.
It's being aired other places and
other people are distributing it offline,
but YouTube's really the main way that
people access the videos.
It really started off very organically and
I was helping cousins
and family members and
it seemed to be working well.
I was tutoring them remotely.
I was in Boston, I'm in
Northern California now,
but they were in New Orleans.
When I was doing this
one-on-one tutoring with them,
it seemed to be very effective.
I just kept thinking of
how could I make it scale.
There's actually a software piece that
I started working on at first and
a buddy of mine said,
"Why don't you put some
videos in the software?"
By the time I got over the idea that
I didn't think of it
(laughs), I started recording
a couple of videos and the
videos are what really took off.
I think it's just the
low barrier for people
to use it, even my own cousins say that
I'm better on YouTube than I am live.
Jon: (laughs)
Sal: Pause and repeat
me and they don't like
the video's judging them
the way I (laughs) ...
I put it out there and I think as a fellow
software engineer, you can
appreciate how fun it is
when people actually
use something you built.
When I just put it out there,
I've written hundreds of
pieces of software that
absolutely no one uses
and just put a couple
YouTube videos out there and within a day,
at least when I started,
20 or 30 people were
using them and some of them
would write notes saying,
"I got an A on my Algebra
exam because of this," or
"I feel prepared to go
back to college next year."
Some of them were, "I
was going to drop out
until I saw something like this," so
you just get one note
like that, you're like,
"This has more impact than I've ever had
doing anything else!" so I just kept
making the videos and
the traffic just kept
picking up organically
and it started to become
pretty clear that there
was a need being addressed.
Jon: So you've actually decided
to try to reconfigure your life,
or you have reconfigured
your life around this,
away from most recently,
financial services?
Sal: Yeah. When I first
started doing this,
I was originally tutoring my cousin Nadia
in New Orleans, they had just visited me
in Boston after my wedding.
I was a hedge fund analyst in Boston and
I was a hedge fund analyst until this past
September and while my
day job was in finance,
I had already reconfigured
my life around this.
Pretty much every waking
moment where I felt that
my wife wouldn't feel that I was being
completely delinquent of my family duties,
I would sneak away and
start doing YouTube videos.
I'd also work on the software that would
give people exercises
to do so I could track
what they were doing.
I've kind of just come to
terms with the fact that
this is what I think I
should be doing all the time
so in September I quit
my job and I've been
doing it full time, and I
haven't looked back since,
although my bank account
is slowly depleting,
so hopefully I'll figure out a way to
make that at least a "not deplete".
Jon: I am certain that you will and
I hope that people who
will be listening to this
can maybe help with that because this is
clearly what you should be spending your
time doing and I think
you've written somewhere
that you realized this
was the way you could
have the most leverage
and do the most good
and have the most fun.
Sal: Oh yeah! Just think about it ...
It's such a simple thing,
I could do a video on
the Fundamental Theorem of Calculus and
it might take me maybe if it's something
I knew before I even started doing this,
I don't have to prepare much and
it takes me 10 or 20
minutes to do the video
and I put it up there.
Literally millions of people,
for as long as the internet exists,
can use that video.
My or your great grandchildren
could use that video
so just in terms of the
return on time invested
or the return on mental capital invested,
however you want to view
it, is mind-boggling.
Jon: It's an astonishing
amount of leverage,
but what this also points to is that,
I was watching a ted talk that Bill Gates
gave recently and part of the video was
discussing education ... And you know from
the software business, that there's this
mime about there being
a really big difference
between an average software engineer and
a great software engineer; it's not just
twice as good, it's [overdirect] magnitude
difference, or at least this is the claim.
He was making that same
argument in the realm
of education and that the Gates Foundation
had been looking into
this and had concluded
that it's the same, right?
That there are some teachers who are just
way, way better than average and how
can we leverage that?
What you're doing is
a perfect illustration
of how we could leverage that.
I want to ask you about ...
Clearly you're a great
teacher and you love to do it,
but when did you realize that?
What is it about you and how you think and
how you present things
and how you communicate?
Have you analyzed what it is that
you think is effective?
Sal: I've tried to. I
think about that myself.
The idea of putting instruction on the web
and letting people use it isn't new,
I wasn't the first person to think of it,
so I do introspect a lot as to why these
videos have seemed to have struck a chord
with people and gotten a lot of traction.
I think it's a couple of things...
You ask when did I realize it?
I think this is true of a lot of people,
it's probably true of yourself,
or a lot of people who do well in the
Math and Sciences, is
they kind of go beyond
what's going on in the classroom and
make connections on their own.
If anything, they get frustrated by
what goes on in the classroom.
They see otherwise intelligent
peers memorizing facts
and not really caring
about the actual intuition,
and because they didn't
care about the intuition
in their junior year, when
that same idea pops up
in the senior year, it's like
they've never seen it before.
It would boggle my mind,
you're relabeling the same
concept over and over.
I've always had the frustration.
I've always been someone that always liked
to ponder what I was
learning as opposed to,
and sometimes it was
at my detriment because
you only have so much time in your day
and you can either do what the teacher
tells you to do or you can ponder.
The pondering might pay
off in the long term,
but not doing what the
teacher tells you to do
is what will hurt you in the short term.
That was kind of my
frustration with my education
throughout high school and college.
I was kind of the guy
who'd skip class a lot
and just try to read a
book, then read other books
and talk to my friends about the concept
as opposed to necessarily going to classes
because I felt I was either lost in class
or I was bored in class.
On a good class, maybe
there'd be 10 minutes
where it was catering
to me and so that was
also a very frustrating experience.
It really felt like there
must be a better way.
When I started tutoring my cousin Nadia,
I started tutoring her
as a friend, or a cousin
as opposed to a teacher.
I think that tone, if
I had to pick one thing
that has kind of resonated with people,
it's this tone that ...
I got a note the other
day on the YouTube Channel
where, "You teach more like
a friend than a teacher."
Jon: Yeah, conversational tone.
Sal: You interpret that in multiple ways,
but I think that's the core issue ...
That the tone doesn't turn people off.
The next thing what I touched
on in my own experience
is that I'm really big
on making connections.
I get a lot of letters
and you can almost sense
the anger from the students where they
communicate that their teachers think
they're making it easier
for the students by
not giving the intuition,
by not giving the depth
or making the connections because they
kind of think that the
students just need to
learn the mechanics.
I get letter after letter saying because
you get the intuition,
because you give the common sense
why this is just a mathematical way of
expressing something that
makes a lot of sense,
it actually becomes a lot more easy and
a lot more intuitive.
I think if you combine that with ...
YouTube used to limit me to 10 minutes and
I've gotten letters from
researchers telling me
that it's been established that 9 minutes
is about as long as
someone can really focus
and pay attention without
taking a mental break.
I give credit to YouTube for that.
I now can record a little
bit longer than 10 minutes,
but I think that's a big thing.
The other thing, and
this was just a complete
side effect of me trying to do it as
cheaply as possible without fancy video
equipment is, you don't see my face and
I've been told by a lot of people that
that keeps it from being a distraction.
It actually makes it very easy for me to
make the videos, I don't have to shave or
wash my face (laughter)
before I make every video.
I just have to make sure ...
Jon: The process that you use is
apparently delightfully low-tech.
It looks to me like you're using tools
as simple as Windows Paint
and I don't know what,
but it's nothing fancy, right?
Sal: No, the first time where I decided to
make the video, I said, "How can I make a
decent video for my
cousins?" and I literally
took Microsoft Paint,
made the background black,
just because I thought it would look nice,
like a chalkboard, and
I used some shareware
screen capture software, it was like a
"free for 20 days" and then you gotta pay
$20 after that, I got myself a $20 headset
and $60 Wacom Pen Tablet
and I started doing it.
Actually, the production
quality was pretty good.
The first, I would say,
4 or 500 videos were done
exactly like that and you can see,
if you see some of the earlier videos,
they're now upgraded slightly,
but not really that much.
One of the users just sent me a license
to Camptasia; I think there's
other things I could use
as well, that would do
screen capture fairly well.
I now use a slightly better
art program that at least
it's a little bit sensitive
to pressure on the
pen tablet, but it's
still pretty low-tech.
Jon: Yeah, exactly.
It's interesting because
when I got started,
I was actually, if you look on Wikipedia,
I'm the person whose
name is associated with
the word "Screencast"
because I got interested
in that stuff some years ago and actually
ran a little ... Because
I was making these
software demos using
Camptasia and its predecessors
and got real interested in that process.
At a certain point, I got to where
I was making pretty
highly-produced kinds of things
that were tightly edited
and that was interesting
to do that process, but at a later point,
I started to rethink
that and at one moment
I remember a friend of mine, his name is
Chris [Gemignani] and
he's an Analytics and
Visualization person,
and every once in a while
he makes these screencasts to show people
things that he can teach
them in say, Excel.
He made one of these and it was full of
stops and starts and you know,
"Oh, I didn't mean to do it that way," and
"Let's back up and try another path," and
we talked about it afterwards and he said,
"You know, I felt like I
should edit that stuff,
but then I realized in a way, if I did,
I wouldn't be giving
people their true insight
into the process of how I think about
these things and how I do these things."
In fact, the unedited style wound up being
better and I think maybe
that's true for you, too.
Sal: Oh absolutely. That's probably one of
the top three in terms of why ...
It was really out of laziness initially.
Jon: (laughs)
Sal: It was for my cousins, I was like,
"I don't care what they
think. I'm doing this
out of my own ... ," so
I would put it out there.
I wouldn't do the problem
before I made the video,
so they saw me doing the
problems the first time.
Every now and then, I
would go down one route
and say, "Wait, that's
not right," and I would
back up a little bit.
That's something that
frankly, no one ever sees.
Your lecturer in your
high school Trigonometry
class, they have done the
problem ahead of time,
or they have the solution
in front of them.
You just see the finished product,
you don't actually see
the thought process.
I think to actually see
someone stumble around
a little bit, who you
respect, who you realize
knows what they're doing,
but still they stumble
around and see kind of the art of solving
a problem I think is
something you'll never see
in a traditional lecture or textbook.
Jon: That might also imply
that you do relatively
less prep than another
person might imagine
would be necessary because
thinking on your feet
is part of the process.
Sal: Now I kind of
embrace that idea now that
there's more viewership,
I feel like I should
prepare more and make it more polished,
but I kind of fight that
instinct and I still
want to keep them relatively raw.
I want to make them easy to watch,
but I get a lot of letters,
people appreciate these ...
There's the college board SAT book and
I did all 400 Math
problems and I literally
did them in real time so ...
Literally like sitting
on my shoulder while
I take an SAT exam which is a kind of,
I don't think a lot of people will expose
themselves in that way,
but I think it's an
incredibly valuable experience because you
don't actually get to
see that in real life.
Jon: In so many ways, we
never get the opportunity
to look over the shoulder
of a practitioner,
of any discipline.
This has been one of my biggest hopes for
the medium of internet
video, as a matter of fact,
is that exactly that becomes possible.
I've thought a lot about how in earlier
incarnations of human society,
that was really the norm.
When you were living
in tribal or a village
kind of situation, the
work that people did
was visible to you, right?
You just had to look and
see what people were doing.
It was just out there in the open and so
part of education was just
seeing what people did.
In a funny kind of way,
I realized that when
got to this mode where
we were all in cubicles
with keyboards and screens,
but were communicating
through email and communicating through
these other sort of mediated channels,
in a way, we actually lose the ability to
watch other people, to
see how they work with
their tools to see how
their minds work, right?
So like with capturing that
is a really interesting
possibility for the
medium of internet video,
and you're a great illustration of that.
Sal: I 100% agree and I think that extends
even beyond what I'm doing.
I won't name him because the story isn't
flattering to his
company, but he's kind of
used my example and he does analytics
at a company and he was
running some reports.
Instead of writing a white paper on what
this report means or how do you run it,
like you would traditionally
do in a corporation,
he told the CEO of the company,
"I have this buddy, he
does this thing on YouTube
using Camptasia. How
about I do the same thing?
Instead of running a white
paper on how to do it,
how about I just capture
my screen while I do it
and I'll talk out loud and ... ."
I thought it was a brilliant idea.
What better way than the guy who's kind of
writing it to learn from
looking over his shoulder
how he does it, but she
thought it was silly.
Just because I think
it's not how the other
corporations do it or it's not how the
corporation she worked for did it.
I think it's going to happen.
I think a lot of these
short technical papers
are going to become
obsolete because people
can just look over someone's shoulder
and see how they do it in real time.
Jon: There's a video
that you may have seen by
this guy, Hans Rosling.
He wrote the Gapminder
software which is this
pretty incredible data
visualization, he's given
a couple of Ted talks,
and what you realize
when you see him giving
one of these presentations,
is that it's only
partly about the high quality
animated visualizations
which the software can produce.
It's also about how he performs
the presentation around that, so it's the
combination of him using the software
along with his voice, along with his body
in this case to illustrate.
That is incredibly powerful.
What I wanted to get to, though, was where
are the limitations still
and how can we address
them ... so one thing a person doesn't
get to do is interact with you.
It's one way in the
course of these videos,
so it's not sort of a complete replacement
for much or some of
what happens in school,
it's however, a useful
compliment and I have
read some indications
that people are getting to
combine your stuff with classrooms in
interactive settings.
So what do you think about that?
Sal: When I started this,
that was kind of my sense;
it doesn't have the interactivity of
a live one-on-one session,
but I've come to the
conclusion, I don't
want to be too grandiose
about its potential,
but I do think that it's
hands-down better than
the professor sitting
in front of a classroom
of 300 students and
just lecturing a prepared
scripted lecture to them.
One, that's kind of
artificial, it's a 90 minute
long thing, it's probably
not catering to all
of the students, some of
the students are lost,
some are bored, they might be sleepy,
it's just not the time ...
Jon: There's no question about that.
Sal: So here you're getting
it when you want it,
you're getting it in granular chunks,
and you can pause, repeat
if I say "orthogonal"
and you don't know what that means,
you can pause and look it up on Wikipedia,
you can go look at the
other video that I've done
on orthogonality and fill in
the blanks just to review.
I think on a lot of levels,
like my cousin said,
I'm better in a lot of
lectures ... Would be better on
YouTube than live.
Then there's also the
opportunity to really
tweak it where YouTube
gives me data on where
attention span drops off from my videos,
so if something unusual
happens in one of my
videos, I can go back to that point,
see what happened, maybe
record another video
if it's because I threw
out a weird concept
or I skipped a step or whatever.
Jon: Exactly.
Sal: So there's also this
potential of really tweeking.
That's why I want to do this software,
and I've been working on the software,
because I want to see
how people interact with
exercises before and after
the video interaction.
Attention span is one thing,
but I also want to see
whether they learned.
You can imagine a world
where you make a video
or I make a video or we
make multiple versions
of the same video and
we just see which ones
work best for different people.
Jon: Absolutely.
Sal: There's things that have never been
imagined with traditional.
The limitation I think,
is just that notion that
there's this individual who
cares directly about you.
When I worked first
worked with my cousins,
I think it's that idea
of my 12-year-old cousin
feeling like her, at the
time I was 26-year-old,
cousin who took time out
of his day to mentor her.
I think that's incredibly,
incredibly valuable.
Frankly, that's not going on in the school
system right now, right?
Right now you're lucky if
you have a conversation
with your teacher in
a class of 30 and it's
usually the problem kids who are having
the most time with the
teacher and it's not
a positive interaction.
Jon: I'll tell you a
funny story about some
other educational videos that I've seen.
I catch a lot of this
stuff in podcast form
and at one point I was
kind of auditing a course
on Evolutionary Biology out
of, I think it was Berkley,
so I remembered actually
something I had seen
in that course a couple
of years before and
I wanted to use that
insight in something I was
writing on my blog.
I went back to try to find it and
when I went back to look at it,
I wound up doing the video instead of
the audio like I usually
do, and my daughter,
who was just getting
ready to enter college,
was looking over my shoulder while I was
playing this video and she said,
"So, do the students just sit there?"
(laughter)
Jon: I was like, "Yeah." In a
large lecture, they do, right?
But then the other weird
thing about that was
that when I finally found
that installment of the
course, he wasn't as good
... What they had done
is they had replaced
this semester's version
with the version from two
years ago that I had seen.
He'd been better two years ago.
It was like he had the
more effective version
so why not just can
that and reuse that and
use the class time for supplementary
kinds of things, or
interactive kinds of things.
Sal: I've got several other teachers,
they're starting to assign
the videos instead of
reading and homework and then you do your
homework in class.
That's where you really benefit from;
one, having the teacher there, even more,
having your peers there.
Jon: Exactly. I think that
will be really fruitful.
Something else that I'm interested in is
the notion that you
talked about caring about
the intuition and
transmitting the intuition ...
That happens in a pretty
personal way for you,
so what we get is this
view through your eyes
of how these intuitions made sense to you,
which is great because a lot of times that
doesn't come front and center.
If we start to get a
few more people like you
out there as well and we
can start to triangulate
on these things, it'll
be even better because
ultimately, there might
be some other person
like you might have a
way of thinking about it
that works better for me ...
Sal: Absolutely.
Jon: And if I could
access the context of a
particular subject, if
I could triangulate and
assemble, "Well, here's
Sal's way of thinking
about it and here's somebody else's way
of thinking about it,
if I could pull these
things together ... " which you know,
just through tagging
things on services like
YouTube wouldn't be
that hard to let happen
in a pretty loosely coupled way.
Sal: Oh yeah, just from
people reviewing it or
tagging it, you could
start to understand what
will respond with
different people or maybe
people could use multiple viewpoints,
but then if you really do couple that with
exercises where you're
able to track everything
and do some analytics,
then you can do some
pretty profound and really
scientifically determine
what works for different people.
Jon: Right. So say a little bit more about
the software you're
working on, what it will do
and where it's going.
Sal: It already exists on
the side, I've actually
just had to [port it and app end] because
too many people were using it which is not
a bad problem, but when
you're the support staff
and engineering staff ...
The idea's very simple;
it starts at 1 + 1 = 2,
it just generates random problems and
each module is like a concept,
like basic addition; 1
+ 1 = 2, 2 + 3 = 5 ...
You got to get 10 in a row.
Once you have 10 in a row on that,
and that's something that doesn't
happen in the school system,
no one expects you to get 10 in a row.
They expect you to get
70% and then you move on.
You get 10 in a row and then it's kind of,
if you can imagine a no-directed graph,
I have something called
a "Knowledge Map" and
your basic addition,
once you get 10 in a row,
you've then fulfilled
the prerequisites for
Level 2 Addition and Basic Subtraction.
Those fulfill the
prerequisites and you have this
no-directed graph, right
now it goes up through
pretty much all of Algebra
2 and Trigonometry.
The videos on YouTube go well beyond that.
They go into college-level
Math, Physics and
Chemistry, but the software,
the idea is to have
it at least cover everything
you would have to know
for the SAT, the ACT or take the GED.
The problems are randomly generated,
so if it takes you 500
problems to understand
negative exponents, you're going to get
500 problems and in the process,
it's tracking everything
you do and it knows when ...
The videos are coupled into it so if you
get a problem, if you know how to do it,
you can type in the answer.
If you don't know how to do it,
you can click "Hint", it'll give you the
steps for that exact problem.
If you still don't know how to do it,
you can click "Video" and the video from
YouTube will pipe in.
What I kind of envision
doing is closing the
loop between instruction,
practice and assessment
and making them all happen simultaneously
as opposed to the traditional model where
I lecture to you, I
give you homework which
you do in a complete
vacuum without any feedback
because the textbooks aren't giving you
any feedback and you may or may not know
how to do it, and then
we kind of keep going
in that cycle for a week or two and then
I give you an exam, you get a C,
so you clearly have some deficiencies,
but too bad, we have to
move onto the next concept.
The model here is just close the loop and
don't let anyone have any deficiencies
before they move on.
Jon: Is it also the case
that you're starting
to get telemetry that's
telling you something
about the videos, how
they're being used and
what the before and after comparison is?
Sal: The software
integration, I've done it
pretty heavily with a
couple of summer camps
out here in the Bay Area
and I haven't gotten
to the point yet where
I'm testing two videos
on the same concept.
I don't have a lot of
multiple videos for the
same concept yet, so I'm
tweaking on that level,
but we have seen, we
did it with a group of
rising 8th graders; these were low and
middle income, mainly minority students,
and this was a summer program to get them
prepared for Algebra and pre-Algebra.
We saw it. When we started the students at
1 + 1 = 2, there were just
some subset of students
who had just very, very
basic deficiencies;
subtracting decimals or
multiplying negative numbers.
You could see it in the
data, they spent a little
more time on those concepts and everyone
else in the class, everyone
else thought it was
just a review, but these
students, it was a gap.
Once they got through that gap,
they raced forward and
they were just as good
as anybody else.
I think that speaks to
why there's a lot of ...
If you go into an Algebra
class, and there's
a lot of great teachers
with high potential
students talking past each other because
the teacher can't address
the arithmetic issue
and the student may
not even know they have
that deficiency, or if they
do, they're embarrassed
to bring it up, so when
you allow people to
do this at their own pace,
you do see it in the data
that it's actually hard to predict who's
going to end up at
different points because
if you give someone the
time to fill in their gaps,
you might have thought
that they were a slow
student before, but
once that gap is filled,
they actually progress quite fast.
Jon: It seems on the one
hand, unimaginable that
we could be here in the
21st century and not
have widely-available
tools online already for
people to do those kinds of things,
to do those kinds of remediations,
but on the other hand, I
guess it seemed kind of
unimaginable that millions
of people would be
driving past this freeway intersection ...
(laughter)
Nobody bothered to tell
them where North 5 was.
Sal: The freeway intersection,
that one's actually,
in the education context,
there's some obvious
forces as to why that doesn't exist today.
I think everyone who's trying to innovate
in education is trying to do it within the
current context so
they're trying to go into
school systems and try
to incrementally change
what teachers are doing
one way or the other.
It's very hard to move
the beast, so to speak.
Then you have all these people on the
for-profit realm and I don't know,
they're just trying to sell something for
$19.95 a month and I
don't think they're ...
They're thinking too deeply about how
to do it right, regardless
of economic consequences.
Jon: You're right. I think
it almost has to come
from the outside and ...
I don't know if you know
Graham Glass, he's a
friend of mine and he's
working on service called EDU 2.0 ...
Sal: EDU 2.0?
Jon: You might be curious about that.
He's coming at it partly from a courseware
perspective, but also very
much from a project-based
learning perspective
where the notion is ...
It's kind of like this, right?
I could have in my
school, I could have a kid
who's interested in, I don't know,
making and flying rockets, and there might
or might not be somebody in the school who
could mentor the kid.
If there is, then you
have one of those lucky
circumstances where the kid has a great
experience and if not,
that capability goes
untapped in the kid, but on the internet,
we have the possibility to bring people
together across time and space, right?
So you have the possibility of bringing a
mentor in from someplace
else and assembling
mentors and students
in that way and letting
them actually then pursue the stuff that
excites them and do things, that's a nice
complimentary model;
but again, he's coming
completely from the
outside and I think that's
probably where all the interesting action
is going to be, it's going to have to be.
Sal: I agree. I think
that's where it's all going.
You have similar to Kahn
Academy has video content,
it's going to have
software, it's going to do
analytics on what's working
for different students
and where the different
students are, but then
you overlay that with
kind of a peer-to-peer
interaction like you just described where
the software knows that for Sal,
the videos haven't been enough and even
the software, he's struggling with it,
I know his schedule and
I know a schedule of
a young woman in Mexico City who's proven
through the site that she
knows what she's doing
and she's a high-regarded tutor,
maybe she might be the same age as Sal or
a little older or a practicing engineer or
who knows what and you pair them up.
You can even record the
interaction and then
you capture the data,
the before and after,
of Sal's performance and his ratings.
Then all of a sudden, you have a very rich
kind of peer-to-peer across time and space
interactions amongst people all over.
Obviously that has other
implications beyond
just teaching people Math.
It can do a lot in
terms of just awareness.
Jon: Yeah. Another guy
I should mention here is
Tim Fahlberg who's a Math teacher.
He got interested in
making, well he actually
has a coined term for
these things; Mathcasts.
He's been doing them with
Camptasia for a long time.
One of the great things
that he told me about
a project where they were working with,
I think it was elementary school kids
in Australia, is that
he wound up having those
kids make educational
videos for each other.
They got to be the
teacher and in the process
of teaching, as you do when teach,
they also learned really well.
They have a nice little
collection of these
problem-solving videos made
by 4th graders in Perth
or Sydney or somewhere.
Sal: That's huge ...
on a massive scale and
even if you have a thousand versions of
adding negative numbers
from a thousand students,
as you said, just them
going through the motions
of doing it, they're
going to get a lot deeper
understanding, but even better ...
I like to review some of my own.
What's better than notes?
It's your own recording of how you thought
about it two months ago
when you were really
deeply engaged in it,
so you have that aspect
and then you have the
aspect you might be able
to identify the next great
teacher that way as well.
Jon: Exactly. Exactly.
Sal: And I'll throw this out ...
I think great teachers were great when
they were 13. (laughs) I don't think much
happens between 13 and 30.
Jon: I think that's true
and in the Bill Gates
Ted Talk that I just watched,
they said something similar which is that
actually teachers in
their first couple years
go through an experience
curve, but after that
they're pretty much where
they're going to be.
Sal: Right, and you know
in the traditional school
system though, that experience curve
is all around classroom management.
I've talked to some of my friends who are
teachers and they're like,
"You don't have to do
this," and it's true,
I don't have to do any of that.
I think that's where a
lot of the experience
curve is more than ...
You know, you're teaching
30 or 25 kids so it's a
different concept than ...
But I think they should be able to explain
in a patient and empathetic way.
What you know on YouTube,
I think that's something,
once you have a little bit of maturity,
you'll probably be able to do as good as
you'll ever be able to do it.
Jon: Have you gotten
into areas where you are
teaching yourself things that you hadn't
previously known or known well?
Sal: Oh yeah, tons of
... Frankly, that's the
real fun for me is that I
get to revisit some things
that I just did superficially
when I was in school
and now I get to really
dive deep on my own
timeframe without any pressure and really
get to understand what those concepts are.
The one example I was given was entropy.
I wasn't a Chemistry jock in high school.
I just did what I needed
to do to well in the class,
but I didn't know it
intuitively the way I might have
known Math or Computer Science,
so that's been a great experience for me.
I started in September
and I for two months,
I really just became a Chemistry geek.
I would call up my friends
who were professors
at Stanford and MIT and say,
"Hey, let's talk about entropy." (laughs)
It's amazing, I think one
point of [unintelligible]
I got from them is they envied me because
when they were doing their PhDs,
they couldn't go to their advisor and say,
"Let's talk about entropy," because that's
something that you were
supposed to have known
when you took AP Chemistry or
freshman level Chemistry,
but the reality is
very few people do have
an intuition of say,
entropy, including some professors today.
Actually entropy examples,
once I was able to
get the idea distilled in my mind,
I realized that most
explanations out there
were on some level, wrong.
Jon: In what way?
Sal: The way you learn
it in Chemistry class,
the teacher says, "Entropy is disorder,"
which isn't incorrect, but they say,
"A clean room has low entropy and
a dirty room has high entropy."
So you go to the exam, they say,
"This room is dirty, this one is clean.
Which one has higher
entropy?" and you just
kind of write it down.
That's wrong. It's
missing the whole point of
what entropy is. It took me a while to
distill this idea that in Chemistry or
Thermodynamics you have
macrostates and microstates.
Microstates are: you're
looking at a particular
atom and you're looking
at its kinetic energy,
you're looking at its momentum,
you're looking at the
vector of its velocity,
and if you looked at
the microstate of every
little atom in a container,
you could run a computer simulation and
maybe might figure out what might happen
the very next moment ...
Those are microstates.
Macrostates are: you look
at the whole container
and you describe all of the particles,
almost you can think of
statistics for all the
particles, so temperature is a macrostate;
it's the average kinetic energy for all of
the particles; so entropy similarly,
is a macrostate, but it's
almost a metamacrostate.
It's this idea of not what
state are the particles in,
it's how many potential
states can the particles have.
In the messy clean room analogy,
the reason why I say
that's wrong is because
each of those are particular states.
It doesn't say, "A messy
room," it depends on
what level you're
thinking about as states,
but it has the same number, because of its
temperature, its atoms
have the same number
of potential states as the clean room.
I guess I'll give you a
really hot, clean room
with things flying around in the air,
is going to be higher entropy than
a cold, dirty room with different things
(laughs) are flying around in the air.
Jon: (laughs)
Sal: It's the number of
states that something
can have and you can
even translate that into
computer science. It's
the amount of information
you need to describe
the state of a system.
So if something that can have more states,
you need to have more bits to describe its
particular state ... And
that's completely lost,
at least it was in the
Chemistry classes I took.
Jon: That's good. I bet
one of the other areas
that's going to be very
fruitful for you in
coming years is Energy Literacy?
Sal: These are questions ...
A lot of people request
a lot of clean tech
lectures, a lot of
people want me to settle
the global warming debate,
the health care debate,
these are things I look
forward to eventually.
I don't know if I'm
going to be able to catch
up with the kind of new cycle, but I think
there is that opportunity
where I can dig deep
into things and as
objectively as possible.
I think people trust
me because they learned
Calculus from me, that
I don't have a political
kind of ax to grind and I can give them a
fairly objective, hopefully
objective take on things.
Jon: When I say energy literacy,
I'm talking about, to give you an example,
I was looking at some of
your stuff the other day
and I've also been,
recently I've been hanging
around on Wolfram Alpha a lot because it's
a really helpful way of making conversions
between units and
different forms of energy
and matter and so on, and understanding
like I don't know, I
put in my electric bill
was such-and-such kilowatt hours,
it was like 1,200 kilowatt
hours, right, like
"What is that? What
does that really mean?"
It'll give it to you in terms of gasoline.
Sal: That's cool.
Jon: As a society, we are broadly speaking
feeling like we need to
have a better handle on,
"What does this stuff
really mean?" in terms that
we can freely interconvert, and
we're not so good at that.
I went from one of your examples back to
Wolfram Alpha and was thinking,
I guess it was just the elevator that
weighs so much and is
100 meters off the ground
and it's got this much
potential energy and
this much kinetic energy
when it hits the floor,
and I looked at that relative
to gallons of gasoline
and kilowatt hours of my electric bill and
it was like wow, I
wouldn't have thought this,
but apparently the energy
I burn as electricity
in my home in a day could take an elevator
to the top of the Empire State Building
10 or 20 times.
I wouldn't have thought that.
Sal: That's something and it gives people
a context for what a kilowatt hour is,
what a calorie is, any of the above.
Jon: Yeah, because we really
lack those intuitions.
It kind of just struck me because I wrote
about this on my blog and
I realized all my life
I've thought about
electric bills as dollars,
and I mentioned this was my electric bill,
it was this many kilowatt hours and people
wrote in from Belgium and the Netherlands
and they said, "Really?"
What made me surprised was that
I suddenly realized, you know what?
They have an intuition about what it means
to be a quantity of kilowatt hours.
The first order for them
isn't dollars or Euros,
it's kilowatt hours.
That actually means something to them
in a way that it doesn't to us.
I don't know, I thought that was ...
Sal: You're inspiring me to do at least
a couple of videos on it.
Jon: Well listen, I think I should let you
get back to this stuff that you do.
I really don't have a lot else to ask you,
but I just want to thank you for what
you're doing, I think it's brilliant and
I am happy to see it happening.
I'm happy for you to be excited and
enjoying doing this.
I know that you're going to find a way to
make this work out as a profession,
as a career, as a lifetime mission.
Sal: Great, I appreciate it.
I have that gut feeling.
It's being done as a
non-profit, but we need
to get to the point the not-for-profit can
pay my rent.
Jon: In my mind, there's
no way that can't happen.
Sal: Yeah, I'm getting that gut feeling.
Hopefully you'll hear
some interesting news
from us ... I don't want
to jinx us, but we'll see.
Jon: Okay. Thanks a lot, Sal.
Sal: Thanks a lot, Jon.
(jazz music)
Voiceover: You've been listening to
"Interviews With Innovators"
with host Jon Udell.
Our audio files are delivered by
Limelight Networks, the high-performance
content delivery network
for digital media.
Conversations Network is
a 501(c)(3) non-profit
and we need your help.
For a tax-deductible
donation of as little as
$5 per month, you can support this channel
and the rest of the Conversations Network.
Please visit conversationsnetwork.org
to become a member and help us continue to
bring our programs to the world for free.
The post-production
audio engineer for this
program was Jon Udell.
Our website editor was Joel Tscherne.
The series producer is Joel Tscherne.
This is Phil Windley.
I hope you'll join me
next time for another
great edition of
"Interviews With Innovators"
on IT Conversations.